what percentage of the competence
hierarchy is influenced by potentially
an exertion of oppression forgive me let
me give you an example for example let's
go ahead and take our friendly Lobster
yeah let's take the lobster for example
let's say the lobster is a sea floor
dwelling creature and the lobster has
twenty shelters but the lobster only
inhabits two of the shelters but it
doesn't enable the other lobsters to
dwell or reside in the other eighteen
shelters that it doesn't even use
as an example
well
look I mean it's we could we can think
about this one of the things that I
found very interesting about looking at
archetypal representations of
experiential reality is that they're
always balanced and so the fundamental
archetypal representation of the
hierarchy is the wise King and the
tyrant and every hierarchy can be
reasonably represented with narratives
involving the wise King and the tyrant
so the wise king is the part of the
hierarchy that sustains itself and
expands and includes more people right
so that's a functioning polity and the
tyrant is the fact that people operating
within that hierarchy can play zero-sum
games can be willfully blind can be
malevolent can play politics concedes to
be productive can manipulate the system
for their own devices and all of that
and it's obviously the case that every
human institution especially as they
scale fells prey to the tyrannical part
of the archetype that's why big things
fall apart and so when you say well to
what degree is a hierarchy well to what
degree does a hierarchy emerge because
of tyrannical factors the answer is well
it depends on the hierarchy but
generally a non-trivial amount that
scales with size okay but that having
said that that doesn't to say that
something is partially corrupt is a lot
different than saying that it's totally
corrupt